je retirais d'un mot merci de répondre à
nos questions comment expliquez vous ce
paradoxe la corse
championne de la vaccination en france
mais la corse qui déclenche le plan
blanc donc ils prévoient des
déprogrammations supplémentaires en
milieu hospitalier
alors le premier élément c'est que la
corse est une région peu peuplée avec
des structures hospitalières
ils sont limités on a deux autres
principaux bastia et ajaccio avec un
nombre de passants en réanimation qui
est qui est très faible donc l'an
dernier à la même époque on avait dû
libérer des lits en utilisant à un
navire de la marine nationale pour
évacuer sur le continent des patients
donc pour nous la saturation des
hôpitaux se joue à un ou deux patients
prêts il faut être réactif très vite
alors la vaccination ici pour nous ça a
été
c'est telle option qu'on a choisi le
plus tôt possible les gens ce sont les
problèmes de santé se sont mis en ordre
de marche sous sous la baguette on va
dire de chef d'orchestre de la
directrice de la rs et sur les
différentes remis cros région on a vu
apparaître donc d organisation
territoriale propre associant à la fois
les maires et les secrétariats des
mairies des communes qui contacter les
patients pour les les convoquer à des
vaccinations des organisations sur le
terrain avec les professionnels de santé
les des fois les sapeurs pompiers pour
venir en aide aux personnes et aider les
gens à mobilité compliqué arrivés
jusqu'au centre de vaccination qui sont
organisées souvent au plus près des
populations au sein des villages et moi
même organisé hier une journée de
vaccination au sein d'un petit village
d'enppi isolé à plus d'une heure et
demie de route du premier hôpital et du
premier centre de gros centres de
vaccination donc on essaye d'être au
plus près de la population pour être le
plus efficace possible c'est l'option
qu'on a on a choisi et comment est ce
que vous accueillez la déclaration
avant-hier de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé oms qui a condamné des lenteurs
un des campagnes vaccinales je cite
inacceptable dans l'horreur en europe
comment est-ce que vous jugez la
stratégie vaccinale de la france que
faire pour accélérer les choses
alors je dirais que pour avec un peu de
recul un peu
lozeau fille je dirais qu'aujourd'hui
j'aimerais pas être à la place de nos
décideurs parce que j'ai bien
l'impression qui a pas de bonnes
décisions à prendre
quoi qu'en disent les uns et les autres
tout les toutes les décisions à prendre
seront des mauvaises décisions
puisqu'elles seront désapprouvée par les
uns ou par les autres
et quand on vit tous une situation
difficile et plutôt que de se tirer un
peu tous dans les pattes on ferait mieux
d'être un peu plus solidaire et c'est de
travailler ensemble et voir comment on
peut être le plus efficace possible sur
le terrain on a effectivement un gros
problème d'approvisionnement en doses
vaccinales les gens en capacité de
vacciner son prêt et attendre l'arrivée
des doses qui nous sont ont normalement
annoncer la pour les pour la prochaine
quinzaine avec des prévisions qui double
un petit peu ce qu'on avait ces derniers
temps et on prévoit une augmentation
multiplication par six au moins pour
notre territoire des douze des autres
qui vont être acheminés vous êtes
médecin généraliste vos confrères
libéraux est ce qu'ils sont largement
mobilisés pour vacciner la population
encore plus que sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
alors oui ils sont mobilisés à plusieurs
titres puisque sur les dires les centres
au plus près des patients
nous organisons des nous participons
dans sept ans et vaccinodromes entre les
médecins libéraux les médecins retraités
qui ont voulu reprendre du service pour
pour aller vacciner être et se rendre
disponible pour pas trop justement
affecter la prise en charge des autres
patients par les médecins généralistes
on va dire tous ceux qui viennent pour
l'épreuve au train de médecine générale
eh bien on essaye d'avoir une on va dire
une collaboration la plus large possible
ensuite il y en a certains qui vaccinent
au cabinet qu'on vaccine avec eux le
vaccin astrazeneca et du fait de la
mauvaise presse qui l'a eu
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de mal à
redémarrer la vaccination à 100% avec de
l'astra zeneca qui aux yeux de nos
patients n'offre pas assez de sécurité
justement je voulais
vous posez une question là-dessus 1 2
décès en plus en lien avec le vaccin
astrazeneca qui a été renommé à un vague
des vrilles à la rsm recommande aux
personnes ayant reçu ce sérum de
consulter immédiatement un médecin une
plainte contre x a été posée déposé à
toulouse
et puis ce matin on apprend de la part
du régulateur britannique
sept décès à la suite de caillots
sanguins outre-manche au royaume uni est
ce qu'on en fait trop ou pas assez par
rapport à astrazeneca parce que chaque
médicament comporte son lot de risques
qu'un mais d'un autre côté la confiance
de la population semble être perdu 1 par
rapport à ce vaccin
alors quoi qu'il en soit quel qu'en soit
les médicaments qu'on va utiliser que ce
soit des vaccins ou autre on a toute une
phase de pharmacovigilance
dès l'instant où il est utilisé à grande
échelle peuvent survenir des effets
secondaires qui sont parfois peu
fréquent est tardif donc c'est un
travail de tous les jours je crois qui
hier sur une centaine de personnes que
j'ai est vaccinée pour une deuxième dose
de pfizer
j'ai fait j'ai aussi saisi quelques
alors cédé effet mineur un souvent mais
on saisit les effets secondaires dans
ces répertoires et sur des grandes
séries effectivement il peut y avoir
quelques morts ça peut arriver pourquoi
pas ça peut être due au hasard comme ça
peut être dû au vaccin
on le saura peut-être beaucoup plus tard
dans les études épidémiologiques
c'est des choses qui reste à voir moi je
vois qu'un seul chiffre
c'est qu'on approche bientôt des cent
mille morts en france sur sur une année
de coheed et que je ne connais pas de
bac 5 est tué sur 1000 personnes
coincées sa merci thierry dahan d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin généraliste à cotonou
encore ça